badass Aquaman last trailer I'm doing
today yes I did see this Shazam trailer
I made do a video on that I made do it
like I don't know was a bonus Sunday or
Monday video or something I I need to
stop for her today but yes Aquaman
trailer hit and I've been curious to see
this one because while I did enjoy the
Justice League and I certainly liked it
better than BBS it was not a complete
course correction so right now Wonder
Woman still stands out a bit as the
anomaly within the DC EU in terms of its
overall quality and again that's not to
say that there's no quality in anything
else but I don't think anything else has
has hit that level and so what about
this kind of needs Aquaman to be of a
caliber and I'm not sure that it will be
but this doesn't convince me that it
won't be so that's something I did I was
surprised how much I enjoy Jason Momoa
as Aquaman I didn't think I would
because the early trailers for Justice
League really put a lot of emphasis on
kind of the what I think a lot of people
Doug dubbed aqua bro you know just the
yeah thing so and there's still a bit of
that here but it didn't it didn't sink
him as a character in that film and I'm
not expecting it to do so here and I
like that the film is leaning in a
certain degree to the silliness not in
that it is treating the character like
he's silly but the silly aspects of the
character it's not shying away from nor
is it trying to explain and justify so
like and then if you've been following
the the film at all we knew this was
going to be the case James Wan had
confirmed this shortly after Justice
League came out so in Justice League in
the one scene that kind of happens down
underwater with Aquaman they create an
air bubble that day that he and Mara
show up in in order to speak to each
other cuz normally sound wouldn't carry
the same way underwater and it was asked
of James Juan are you going to be doing
that throughout the whole I put me I
fell me he kind of shrugged in one well
no they're just gonna talk underwater
which is the right attitude like that's
part of the nature of this character
that and talking to fish are part of his
deal so if you can't roll with that if
you need a realistic explanation as to
the fact that he can just talk
underwater and can't communicate with
fish go watch something else because
Aquaman is not for you yet at the same
time while not abandoning the admittedly
silly or more comic book elements it
also isn't like going uh it isn't like
turning them into the joke that it would
be very easy to do like in an attempt to
seem too cool for its own history which
I think would be very easy for this to
lean into it just seems to be embracing
what Aquaman is the fun that because the
Aquaman is an adventure character
because different heroes are you know we
say the superhero genre but different
heroes are fundamentally different
things or have been at least for the
majority of the run some have changed
over time but you know Batman is
fundamentally a detective
vigilante character and he is but
usually best used to tell those kinds of
stories
Iron Man when he was first introduced
basically prior to the movie was
basically an espionage character he was
constantly going up against the Soviets
when the Cold War was still going on
that was the kind of story you told with
that character and Aquaman is an
adventure character by adventure I mean
that kind of rollicking fun you know we
come in we save the day we have a good
time we kind of wink at the camera you
know it's all good that's that is
Aquaman that's his history that's his
roots and that's again I'm not saying he
never the writing never deviated from
that but that's who he is fundamentally
as a character and I feel like this is
embracing that while giving it just a
little bit enough sort of gravity to the
character and the situation that I think
is warrant
because if you aren't gonna do a movie
especially a superhero movie in some
ways you kind of have to go I don't want
to say like big like apocalyptic but
like you need stakes you need Series
stakes and they either need to be super
personal meaning we're really invested
in the characters or just big scale
which this seems to be going for more
and that's fine I the performances seem
solid nothing really stood out to me as
good but nothing stood out to me is bad
either and that for a DC film that's uh
that's a good thing that's no small
thing
I the the effects are pretty solid I
like a lot of the design work I like
some of the the looks of the underwater
creatures we see I love the shot of him
diving into the water with the flares
leading I think it's the trench away
from that boded they're all following
that huge wide shot oh that was gorgeous
I love that and it was funny I hadn't
decided I don't think it actually pans
out this way but I did have the thought
when he was like had the bits of him
challenging arm for the throne I'm like
are we watching Black Panther from Kill
longers perspective and I don't think
that's actually the case it's absolutely
not intentionally the case cuz they were
in production at around the same time um
and I don't think even functionally
that'll end up being the case but I did
I had that thought and I found myself
wanting to share it regardless I think
if I was gonna make any complains and
this is nitpicky I the the jumping out
of an airplane without a parachute thing
that's kind of become a tired bit and I
don't think I'd even object to it being
in the movie especially because I do
kind of like the you know red heads line
but at the same time it is a little bit
it's been used a lot especially in
trailers so I don't mind that that's
probably gonna be in the movie I am a
little bit like did we need that in the
trailer because that's not like a moment
that feels unique and you're like oh
that's that stuff like yeah I saw that I
saw that in Iron Man and I saw that in I
guess it was Avengers that Captain
America did it or no it was Winter
Soldier but in any case it liked it
starting to feel it's not quite blue
beam in the sky but it is starting to
feel like a bit of a superhero staple in
a way that maybe don't put that in your
trailer but other than that like I I've
no anticipation this is gonna be some
sort of great monumental film but I have
nothing of substance to complain about
in this and that's that's a good start
that's that solid as far as I'm
concerned and a trailer for an Aquaman
film which a film which was a film that
you know prior to the release of Justice
League
I had only morbid curiosity in I you
know this is solid and much like the
Godzilla trailer it makes me more a it's
a film I was probably gonna say
regardless but it makes me more
interested in seeing it makes me a
little bit excited to see what its gonna
be like and I was curious before now I'm
actually interested so that's an uptick
in my interest level that's a positive
for the trailer I call that a win
Aquaman trailer your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop setting down the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do I won't list it but I
will mention the patreon because that's
kind of the big one for me but links for
that and a bunch of other stuff it's all
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]